now back to the latest developments on
michael flynn if you've been paying any
attention to the news this afternoon we
suspect you have been
you know there is a passionate debate
underway right now among political
partisans over the justice department's
decision to drop the case against
general flynn
they're screaming but there shouldn't be
a debate because there actually
isn't a debate about why the case was
dropped we already know
doj officials explained it in detail
today read the filings
it's worth it they're online clearly
almost nobody commenting on the case has
read them and they should
the documents are shocking not to
republicans or democrats but to
americans
we've outlined much of what we knew
about the flynn case in previous
segments on the show
how a corrupt fbi official called peter
strzok decided to derail mike flynn
using any means necessary at one point
strzok considered charging flynn
under something called the logan act the
logan act is a 220 year old law
that in the entire span of american
history has never been used to convict a
single person in fact no one's even been
indicted under the logan act since
before the civil war and by the way it's
probably unconstitutionally probably
couldn't do it now if you wanted but
struck didn't care
his goal was to keep the investigation
going whether he had a legal
justification for doing that
or not by january 4th of 2017 the fbi
had already completed its investigation
of flynn which was thorough
after four months of looking into flynn
they found quote
no derogatory information of any kind
linking flynn to russia
now fair investigation the kind that we
have a right to expect as americans
would have ended right there
and according to the doj today it should
have ended right there quote
the department does not believe there
was a legitimate basis to investigate
and prosecute the designated national
security adviser
for communicating with a foreign
ambassador and seeking to modify
geopolitical tensions in advance of the
inauguration of the next president
and that's the essence of it right there
michael flynn did not commit a crime
and they knew it how did they know
because the fbi had already tapped
michael flynn's phone
which itself is a shocking outrage
completely unacceptable in a free
country
that for some reason nobody in
washington seems to notice or care about
they should
because the fbi already knew what flynn
had said in the call in detail
there was the department announced today
quote no justification or need to review
mr flynn as to his own personal
recollections
of what had been said because they knew
in other words the whole thing was a
setup from the first moment now we know
this for certain we're not speculating
because we have peter strzok's text
messages
to his creepy government lawyer
girlfriend lisa page
but what if we didn't have those text
messages we almost didn't
at first you'll recall the fbi claimed
they'd been lost due to some
technical glitch so we almost didn't
find out what really happened
in this case michael flynn almost went
to prison and that gets to the nub of
all of this the most important question
of all how often does the fbi set people
up
how many other lives have they destroyed
without the public knowing about in
other words this isn't about
michael flynn it's about you
it's scary to think about that most
people in washington seem determined not
to think about their intent
on excusing all of this elon omar was
among the first to chime in on the news
today
white privilege at work she tweeted omar
didn't explain
what in the world mike flynn's case
might have to do with his skin color
which he cannot control
but she denounced the decision as racist
anyway surprised
you shouldn't be surprised ilhan omar is
a person who clearly married her own
brother in an immigration scam
who passionately hates the country that
saved her who reduces
every conceivable issue to the most
vicious kind of race baiting
can a single human being actually be as
loathsome as ilhan omar's it's hard to
believe
she's like a parody of repulsiveness
sometimes you doubt she really exists
the rnc must have created her
we can't confirm that of course we can
say with confidence the rnc did not
create
cable news the dummies there were almost
as angry as ilhan omar was
watch jeb bush's former flack take a
break from sucking up to professional
harvey weinstein enablers like noah
oppenheim
to lecture the rest of us about smear
campaigns
mike flynn's lawyers have been engaged
in a smear campaign
very very similar torn out of the same
playbook as the smear campaign donald
trump ran
against many of the same fbi leaders the
idea that the justice department
could do this you called it stunning
it's past stunning
this is the collapse of the justice
department this
is a political and incredibly
destructive thing to the rule of law
it's not good for the rule of law it's
not good for morale
and it's not a fair outcome in this case
today we've seen the political
corruption of the justice system that
mike flynn has long been calling for
the justice department had nothing to do
with this this was the white house
100 the fix is in this is an absolute
injustice
so what exactly are these people saying
what argument are they really making
mike flynn was set up by corrupt law
enforcement officials
they suggested their goal was to quote
get him to lie so we can prosecute him
or get
him fired that's not speculation the fbi
wrote that down on paper
flynn faced a maximum of five years in
prison
are the people you just saw really
arguing that flynn's prosecution was
legitimate are they arguing he should
serve the time behind bars
it's enough to make you dizzy keep in
mind these are supposed to be called
liberals okay so whatever happened to
their commitment to civil rights
to fairness in fact there's nothing
liberal about the arguments they are
making this is the most brutal kind of
power politics disguised with lies
this moment represents the full collapse
of an apolitical justice department
wrote cnn's legal analyst susan
hennessey msnbc's justice analyst
matthew miller agreed with that quote
barr is giving flynn treatment that
would not be available to any other
american
and just in case you wondered if all
these responses were coordinated because
of course they were
the world's angriest former labor
secretary robert rice wrote this quote
under william barr's stewardship the
justice department has become nothing
more than a political tool for trump to
wield against his enemies and withdraw
against his friends
this is how dictatorships are built
pause and consider this once again it is
head spinning in its falseness
it's the opposite of what's true
dropping the case against michael flynn
means the justice department is now a
political tool
no flip it around 180 degrees the
attorney general dropped the case
because the justice department was
already being used as a political tool
to remove the national security adviser
of the united states that's the whole
point
it's not a debate no honest person could
reach any other conclusions
read the documents yourself but these
are not honest people
these are people who applauded when adam
schiff of california basically
baselessly denounced his political
opponents as russian agents including
this show
naturally schiff himself weighed in
today too he couldn't help himself quote
flynn pled guilty to lying to the fbi
about his illicit russian
contacts his lies do not now become
truths this dismissal does not exonerate
him
wait what is adam schiff the chairman of
the house
intelligence committee now claiming that
a call between the incoming national
security adviser
and the russian ambassador to the united
states is quote in illicit russian
contact he is claiming that this is
insanity
and it's calculated insanity and in the
end hate to tell you
it may work it is entirely possible your
grandchildren will be reading
adam schiff's version of history 20
years from now
that's why they're saying it that's the
goal in the meantime you should consider
what it would mean if unscrupulous liars
like these were ever to take full
control of this country
they know michael flynn is not a
dangerous criminal if he was a dangerous
criminal they'd be working to free him
from jail
no they wanted flynn crushed purely
because he happened to be in the way of
the power they seek
and that's why they're still trying to
put roger stone behind bars
because he mocked them to their faces
and that diminished their authority
roger stone may still go to prison by
the way we'll keep you posted
but the question is how many other
inconvenient americans would they
bankrupt and imprison
if they could let's hope we never find
out
in the meantime you should ignore their
yelping turn it off this is an offense
against equal justice they scream into
the camera
right the very same people who demand
day after day that we hold american
citizens
to completely different standards based
on how they look
now they're telling you justice must be
blind
it's absurd it's insulting the essence
of fairness
in every country at every time is
fairness
fairness what the federal government did
to mike flynn
was demonstrably and provably unfair
and anyone who refuses to admit that in
the face of overwhelming evidence
should not wield power